forgive me Michael can you explain real
quickly what structural devices and I'm
a little unclear
sure well first of all let's just talk
about what structure means structure or
plot structure simply means the sequence
of events what's the sequence of what
happens and when does it happen
so let's say you're writing the script
and you know you want a car chase in it
then is it going to open the movie is it
going to be right as the midpoint is
going to be the climax going to be where
does it occur that's that's a structural
question so what we've been talking
about extensively is my approach to the
overall structure of a story which are
the six stages which are created by
those five key turning points but within
each stage you still have to be smart
about what the sequence of events would
be so there are some other tools you can
use to do that some other structural
tools you can use that will help you
maximize the emotional experience for
the audience so let me give a couple
examples one of those would be
anticipation keep in mind that when we
go to the movies what we like to do is
try and guess what's going to happen
next we're always thinking about oh
what's going to happen and and the movie
you want to create anticipation in the
movie so if you go see John okay now the
other side of the Batman I'm thinking is
judgment starts a classic example of
anticipation but it was sort of because
of the necessity of having a broken
shark all I really had was a dorsal fin
but every time we see the dorsal fin
we're anticipating oh my god here comes
the shark in fact this does nothing to
do with a screenplay but John Williams
had a live anticipation by creating a
theme just for the shark and now I got
to do is here and everybody in the world
knows what those two notes mean and so
that's anticipation so we love that
because we don't want to just sit there
bored and only only enjoy motion right
when it happens we want to think about
the conflict to come because the emotion
goes out of conflict
so that's anticipation but to create
that anticipation there is
another device that's really effective
to use and that's what is known as
superior position superior position
means tell your reader or your audience
something that some of the characters in
the movie don't know because that lets
your audience or your reader anticipate
what's going to happen when the people
who don't know that this is happening or
this exists who don't know what I know
find out what happened what what I know
so the classic example of that would be
in a suspense thriller and then that
means you go to Alfred Hitchcock which
he talked about this all the time he had
an anecdote I used to say and that is if
you have if you're shooting a film and
two people are sitting across the desk
and all at once a bomb that was hidden
in the desk goes off and they're blown
to bits
he would say I'm paraphrasing he said it
much more elegantly he'd say you could
probably squeeze about 60 seconds of
emotion out of that because we'd be
shocked and surprised and be awful and
then the audience was saying okay now
what but he said suppose the camera cut
to the bomb inside the drawer of the
desk and we know it's there but the two
people at the desk don't know then you
could melt that for 10 minutes because
we're thinking where's the bomb squad
get out of the room get out of the room
get out of the room and because we know
that the bomb is there but the two
people at the desk don't know we have
superior position and with that superior
position we can anticipate what's going
to happen and we're anticipating the
horrible violence and we don't want it
to happen so now we're deeply
emotionally involved in that conflict
for a much longer period of time and if
you want a more recent example of that
I'm not going to say too much for the
sake of those who haven't seen it but I
strongly recommend everybody see eye in
the sky and all I will say about that is
for a great example of superior position
we know what's going to happen but the
girl selling bread doesn't know and that
creates tension that lasts in that movie
for at least I would guess
thirty to forty five minutes because
that whole movie in a way is built on
that superior position and anticipation
of conflict a third example of a
structural device that I recommend
highly is a ticking clock
that means you always want to build
conflict in your story you can
exponentially increase the level of
conflict by having whatever the heroes
trying to do be a race against time so
again if you have a thriller it's like
they're rushing to stop the killer
before the killer blows up the bomb in
the cathedral or they're rushing to stop
the bad guy before the bad guy kills the
kidnap victim that they're holding
hostage okay so there's a lot of
examples of it in action movies and
thrillers also though there's a lot of
examples of it in romantic comedies if
you look closely a romantic comedies
very often in the last act of the movie
right before the climax there'll be a
seeing what I call the race to the
wedding and you'll see actually the the
pace speeds up the hero is rushing to
get to the love interest
so in Notting Hill she comes to him and
says that famous line I'm just a girl
standing in front of a boy asking him to
love her and wants to be with him the
Julia Roberts character and will the
Hugh Grant character says no I have to
refuse because I can't have my heart
broken again
he's retreating there's identity so then
he goes to his friend and says did I do
the right thing and all his friends say
yeah yeah that's right it would be a bad
idea and so on until his reflection
character spike comes into the room and
they all tell him he just broke up with
Anna Scott and he turns to you and says
you daft prick because that's him
holding Hiro's feet to the fire and
saying
you're not going with your truth so what
then happens we know and Hugh Grant
knows she's about to leave town and he
has no idea how to reach her except
she's giving a press conference so they
all jump in this little car and go
screaming through the streets of London
to get to the hotel where the press
conference is so he can get there and
declare his love for her before she
leaves town so that ticking clock speeds
up the momentum accelerates the pace
raises the level of conflict and push
more puts a greater obstacle for the
hero to overcome and that makes the
structure more effective
you